but when we read history we come to know
that Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
met War only twice in his life once
before he claimed
prophethood when he was worshiping the
Caba and he kissed the fo of the prophet
and the other time when the first was
revealed to the prophet and when the
prophet was scared and
shivering his wife takes him
to only on two occasions and immediately
after the first way was revealed the
first revelation was given 3 years later
he dies and this Quran continued to be
revealed for 22 and a half years so
imagine Prophet met him only twice how
can he learn from him and he died 3
years after meeting him the last time
after the way started so surely he could
not have learned from warka he was a
Christian Arab he was Arab but he had
converted to Christianity but surely he
could not have learned from him there
are some people who say that the prophet
he learned about the Quran from the Jews
and Christians when he spent time with
them we know that the prophet gave dawa
to the Jews and Christian after going to
Madina 13 years after the Revelation
started so surely he could not have
learned from them and in the discussions
it was the prophet who was giving them
information not the vice versa and many
of the people who he discussed with many
of them accepted Islam so it was the
prophet who was helping them not they
were helping
Prophet furthermore some people say that
maybe learned from people outside Arabia
and we know that Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him he went outside Makkah
before claiming Prophet only
thce mons to
Madina at the age of
six second time between the age of 9 and
11 when he goes along with his uncle to
Syria for a business trip and he goes at
the age of 25 to Syria when he takes the
Caravan of kadijah may Allah be pleased
with her he only
goes outside Makkah thce so to say that
he went outside thce and he learned
everything of the Quran in this three
occasion is absurd furthermore we
realize it's illogical that the prophet
could have learned from somebody El
because he was so busy he was always
surrounded by the people
he was always kept busy by the people
meeting him so much so that the Quran
says that give the prophet a
rest so if he met some people surely
this thing would have been exposed in
history and the enemies of the Prophet
were always keeping a watch on him if he
really met someone secretly surely he
would have been
exposed furthermore one historical
fact that the prophet was illiterate is
sufficient to dispel all these theories
that he copied from somewhere
else and Allah says in the
Quran in Surah anab chapter number 29
verse number
that you were not able to recite any
book before this before this book came
nor were you able to transcribe any
other book before
this or else
the talkers of vanity would have doubted
that means almighty God who has all the
wisdom he knew that people will allege
that this Quran has been written by the
prophet so he s to it that the last and
final messenger Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon was an illiterate was um not
even giving a point to the critics which
is hardly big enough to even hang a fly
Allah is not a even giving a small
chance to the toos of vanity even giving
the slightest excuse that someone would
say that the prophet wrote the
Quran and it's mentioned in Sur chapter
number 7 verse number
157 it says that they follow the
unlettered prophet who mentioned in the
law and gospels mentioned in the
scriptures
here it says that the prophet would be
unlettered illiterate and we find that
there are several Prophecies of Prophet
Muhammad in the Old Testament as well as
the New Testament several times
mentioned in the Bible and it's clearly
mentioned the book of Isaiah chapter
number 29 verse number 12 that the book
will be given to the who is not learned
and when it will be said to him pray
read this he will say I am not learned
and this is exactly what happened when
the first revelation wah came to Prophet
Muhammad Salli wasallam and Archangel
Gabriel said read he
replied I not learned so surely the
prophet being an illiterate could not
have copied from somewhere
else history tells us today that the
first Arabic version of the
Bible the Arabic version translation of
the Bible did not exist when the prophet
was
alive the first version of the Old
Testament was written by R sadon Goos in
900 CE about more than 250 years after
death of the
prophet and the first Arabic New
Testament was written or translated by
arenus in the year
1616 about 1,000 years after the demise
of the Prophet so where is the question
of the Prophet coming from the Bible the
there are many people who say that the
prophet knows bah he copied the Quran
from the
Bible and we do agree that there are
similarities between the Bible and the
Quran not just because there is
Quran that does not mean the Quran has
been copied from the Bible there is a
possibility that both of them have one
common
source and we know that the of all the
revelations was One True almighty
God suppose a student a in the
examination he copies from the textbook
of Science and student B also copies
from the textbook of science that does
not mean B has copied from a or a has
copied from B both copied from the
original Source the textbook of science
similarly the source of all the
revelations it is almighty God and
furthermore
if anyone copies from someone he will
never write the name of the person who
he has copied from the Quran gives due
respect to Prophet Jesus peace be upon
him if he had copied from the Bible why
should he give respect to Jesus peace be
upon him if a person copies from his
neighbor he will not mention that my
neighbor is a good person or my neighbor
is very intelligent in
science so if the prophet copied from
the Bible why does he give due respect
to Moses Jesus peace be upon him and all
the
prophets if we
say that the Quran has been copied from
the Bible because there are common
points then we can say that Jesus Christ
peace be upon bah he has copied from the
Old Testament because there are
similarities between the old and the New
Testament we know that the similarities
are because both have a common source
that is one almighty
God we come to know that in Islam there
are four Revelations the Torah the zabur
the injil and the Quran the Torah is the
the Revelation which was given to Moses
peace be upon him the zabur is the the
Revelation given to David peace be upon
Him injil is the the Revelation given to
Prophet Jesus peace be upon him and the
Quran is the last and final Revelation
which was given to the last and final
messenger Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him even though all the revelations all
the scriptures that came before the
Quran they have not maintained the pure
form they have been corrupted they have
been changed yet
there are many parts of these
scriptures which yet are the
same so if you have to check what is
correct you have to check with the fan
that is the Glorious Quran if it matches
with the Quran we have no problem in
accepting that portion of that scripture
to be the word of God there may be many
human
beings who may not be knowing or having
a knowledge of the Quran or the Bible so
how can we diser which of the two is
right or who has copied from
whom the best test is the test of
science if we put these two scriptures
to the test of science we will know the
difference of chalk and Chiefs when we
read superficially we come to know that
the Bible and the Quran is the same but
if we do a research or we analyze it we
come to know there the difference of
chalk and Chiefs when we read the Bible
it's mentioned in the first book of the
Bible Book of Genesis chapter number
one that allmight God he created the
Heaven and the Earth in six days and
these six days are 24 hours
days mention in the
Bible the Quran too speaks about the
creation of the universe and says
almighty God has created the heavens and
the Earth in six
aams aam is plural of Y one of the
meaning of yum is a 24-hour day but the
other Arabic meaning of yum is a long
period and Epoch today scientists they
say that our universe was created in
billions of years so to say it was
created in 624 days is
wrong but the scientists have got no
objection with the Quran when the Quran
says the heavens and the Earth were
created in six
aams that is six long periods without
defining them to restrict 24
hours furthermore mentioned in the Bible
in the first book book of Genesis
chapter number one verse number 3 to 5
that almighty God he
created the day and the night on the
first day and he created the light on
the first
day it later says in Genesis chapter
number 1 verse 14 to 19 the source of
light that is the stars and the sun they
were created on the fourth day imagine
the effect is created on the first day
and and the cause of the effect on the
fourth day the sun was created and the
stars on the fourth day and the light
from the sun and the star was created on
the first day it's illogical how can the
effect come before the source Quran too
speaks about the creation of the Heaven
and the Earth but does not give this
unscientific sequence furthermore
mentioned in the first book of the Bible
Book of Genesis chapter number one verse
number 9-13 that the Earth was created
on the third day and Genesis chapter
number one verse number 14 to 19 that
the Sun and the moon was created on the
fourth
day we know from science that the Earth
and the moon are the part of the parent
body that is the Sun so to
say that the Earth was created before
the parent body the sun is
unscientific the Quran too speaks about
creation of the heavens the Sun the Moon
and the Earth but it says it was created
simultaneously imagine Prophet Muhammad
sallallah alaihi wasallam copied from
the Bible and he changed the
sequence he says no both were cre
together Bible further says in the Book
of Genesis chapter number one verse 9-13
that almighty God created the vegetables
and the
vegetations on the third day and Genesis
chapter number one verse 14- 19 he
created the sun on the fourth day
scientifically it's not possible that
the vegetation can survive without
sunlight
it's totally
unscientific furthermore the Bible
says in Genesis chapter number
one verse number 16 that almighty God
created two great lights the greater
light the sun to Rule the Day and the
Lesser light the moon to rule the night
the Bible says the light of the Sun as
well as the light of the moon is its own
light
the Bible says the light of the moon has
its own light but the Quran says in
Surah fan chapter number 25 verse number
61 the light of the moon is not its own
light it's a reflected light so imagine
the prophet copied from the Bible and he
made Corrections not the own light it is
reflected
light it's not humanly
possible only one who has this knowledge
is almighty God
there are several examples you can give
a talk only on this and I a debate with
Dr William Campbell on the topic the
Quran and the Bible in the light of
Science and there I've mentioned many
unscientific points mentioned in the
bible time does not permit me to go into
details the various unscientific things
mention in the Bible which is not
mentioned in the Quran for example
according to the Bible Adam peace be
upon him he came into existence about
5,800 years before science tells us that
the human beings came into existence
millions of years before the Quran too
speaks about Adam Alam but does not give
a
date the Bible says in Genesis chapter
number
67 as well as it about Noah and the
flood and it says that the full world
was submerged
underwater at the time of Noah that is
approximately 21st 22nd century BC Quran
too speaks about new
Alam but it does not give it a
date it even speaks about the flood but
it says it was a localized flood only it
flooded the umah the people of new Alam
not the full world today archaeological
evidence shows us that the 11th dynasty
of Egypt as well as the third dynasty of
Babylon they existed without
interruption since 21st 22nd century
BC so archeological evidence says that
what is mentioned in the Bible is
totally wrong there are various examples
we can give hundreds time does not
permit so surely this Quran has not been
copied from the Bible neither it has
been
forged as mentioned in the Quran in
Surah Sada chapter number 32 verse
number one and two it says that do they
say he forged it nay it is a truth from
the Lord so that he may give admonition
to the people to whom no Warner has come
in the past
so surely we can undoubtedly say that
neither Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
the author of the Quran neither did he
copy or plagiarize or learn it from any
other
source further more we
know the Glorious Quran unlike other
religious scriptures or unlike other
story books which are written by human
beings it has a particular
beginning Once Upon a Time
foxes and the grapes Once Upon a Time
lamp and the wolf that the Bible says in
the beginning was
God in the beginning was the
word typical and every story book will
have a sequence sequence you know a
beginning and end in A Serial order but
the Quran is
unique the first verse to reveal of the
Quran is not the first chapter chapter
number one one it is chapter 96 verse
number
one it doesn't have a sequence it does
not start with
Adam and then it continues and goes to n
Alam and M Alam then Jesus peace be upon
him then Muhammad peace
no it has a unique sequence it does not
work like a human
mind because the author is not a human
being
furthermore there are unknown things
mentioned in the
Quran along with it there's a challenge
saying that you do not know
it for example it's mentioned in the
Quran in Surah HUD chapter number 11: 49
saying that you did not know this before
neither the people amongst you knew
it it gives an information and says oh
Prophet you did not know it not even
your people knew
it it's mentioned in s Yu chapter number
12 verse number
two that none amongst you knew it
neither the prophet knew it imagine the
prophet saying when the Quran was
revealed in Arabia he's telling to the
Arabs neither I knew it neither you do
not know it any Arab could have got up
he could have said that I'm an Arab and
I know this answer this I knew it
before the Quran mentions many
incidentes many things
about about the story of the caves many
information and says you did not know
which human being who can write this
book and say you did not know it
before indicating this does not have a
human
origin
furthermore some people say that the
Quran is a deception when we ask them
what is the original of the deception
they give no answer can you point out a
single deception in the Quran they
cannot
answer so how can you say something
which you can logically prove there are
some
people who tell a false thing who make a
false
statement and they fool themselves by
sticking to it for example suppose
there's a person who thinks Mr a is an
enemy he thinks he does not have a
logical proof he has no reason but he
thinks he falsely believes that Mr a
he's manimi the moment he meets Mr a
that person starts behaving like an
enemy to Mr a now Mr a being a human
being he
retaliates why is he treating me as
enemy he retaliates the moment Mr
retaliates the person says Ah didn't I
tell you he's my enemy see they is
retaliating to me so you make a false
statement and you fool yourself by
sticking to the statement
this is what the critics of Islam do
they make a false statement and they
fool themselves by sticking to it
furthermore the
Quran it believes in
reasoning and there are several verses
which talk about reasoning you can
analyze it you can discuss the matter of
the Quran several places including Surah
ibah chapter number
14 verse 52 that here is a message for
mankind let them take warning there from
let them know there is one God let the
men of understanding take
heed many Muslims think that the Quran
discourages reasoning it discourages
arguing with people it discourages
discussing about the Quran with others
and religion with others in fact the
Quran
encourages that you have to discuss with
the other human beings you have to argue
with the other human beings it's
mentioned in the Quran in Surah Nel
chapter number 16 verse number 12
invite all to the way of th Lord with
wisdom and beautiful preaching and argue
with them and reason with them in the
ways that are best most gracious Quran
encourages
reasoning and arguing and discussing but
with hikma and in ways that are best and
most
gracious there is something known
as exhausting the
Alternatives there's a concept known as
exhausting the
Alternatives the Quran says this is from
God if you don't believe in it you tell
me what it is from you tell me from
where it is the Quran says this book is
from God the book is from Allah if you
disagree you give me the answer so
someone will say Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him he wrote the Quran and we
proved earlier he didn't write he lied
why did he lie because of material gains
and we proved it's not possible maybe
for power and glory and we prove that's
not possible maybe for Unity of the
Arabs and we prove that's not possible
someone will say okay did for moral
reformation and we proved it's not
possible guess
guess okay you copied from the Bible and
we proved it is wrong guess when all
your guesses are proved
wrong that means the Quran requires to
be heard it requires respect you have to
believe in
it that this book Quran is from almighty
God and Quran says in several places
that this book is a revelation of Allah
subhana wa tala including Sur jha
chapter number 45 verse number one and
two where it
says that H this is a revelation of the
book from the lord of the worlds exalted
in power and full of wisdom the Quran
says in several places that this book is
the book of almighty God it's mentioned
Surah Anam chapter number 6 verse number
19 Surah Anam chapter number 6 verse
number 93 it's mentioned Surah yusu
chapter number 12 verse number 1 and 2
in Surah chapter number 20 verse number
113 it is mentioned in Surah s chter
number 32 verse 1 to3 in Surah y chapter
number 36 verse number 1 to3 it's
mentioned Sur Z Chapter number 39 ver
number one in Surah GA 40 ver number two
it's mentioned in Surah jha 45 ver
number two it is mentioned in surahman
chapter number 55 verse number 1 and two
it's mentioned in Surah insan chapter
number 76 verse number 23 that this book
The Glorious Quran is from none other
but Allah subhana wa
tala this is known as exhausting the
Alternatives what you have you give you
try it out if you fail to prove it
logically then you have to agree with
what is
mentioned as far as the scientists are
concerned they have a different
philosophy they have a different
approach this approach is known as the
falsification
test the scientist they are so busy
there are so many new theories coming
about they don't have time to analyze it
they say if you have a theory first give
give us a way to prove your theory wrong
if you come about With A New Concept
first give us a way show us a way how to
prove your theory
wrong Albert Einstein in the beginning
of the 20th century he proposed certain
things how does the universe
work along with it he give three ways
how to prove his theory wrong the
scientist they examined for six years
and then they agree it was right now
anyone who gives a falsification test it
deserves to be
heard it doesn't mean the person is
great or the work is great it may be
right may be wrong but anyone who gives
the falsification test it deserves to be
heard there are innumerable
falsification
tests mentioned in the Quran you want to
prove the Quran wrong it is very easy
you try it out very
easy there are some falsification test
which was meant only for that time when
the Quran was revealed some is meant for
today some it will be meant till the
last
day I'll just mention about four or five
because of lack of
time one very good example is about the
story of Abu
lahab Abu lahab he was the uncle of the
Prophet Muhammad Salli wasallam and he
was given this nickname Abu laab the
father of the flame and he was one of
the staunchest enemies of the Prophet
whenever we saw anyone speaking with the
prophet he used to wait moment the
prophet left he used to go to the man
and ask him what did the prophet say did
he say
black it is white did he say day no it
is night he used to speak the
opposite he was one of the staunchest
enemies of the prophet he went out of
the way he lied many a times just to
prove the prophet wrong now there's a
Surah in the
Quran by the name Surah laab chapter
number 111 which all of us know very
well it's recited many times in
the
Etc in this Surah it is mentioned that
Abu laab and his
wife they will burn in the Hellfire
indicating they will never become
Muslims they will never ever accept
Islam now this Surah was revealed about
10 years before the death of Abu
lahab when the Surah was
revealed only thing Abu laab had to
do was accept
Islam and the Quran would have been
proved wrong not actually many of his
companions who were his friends in the
span of 10 years they accepted
Islam Abul laab later on after 10 years
he died in the Battle of bad 10 years he
had
time the prophet was constantly
reminding him for 10
years you accept Islam and the Quran
would be proved wrong so easy only thing
you had to do was say I am a
Muslim finish not that he had to behave
like a
Muslim not that he had to offer Salah
only thing you had to say I'm a Muslim
and finish the Quran have been proven
wrong so
easy very easy he had lied many times
against the prophet he had to lie once
again and the Quran would have been
proved
wrong but he could not because author of
the Quran is almighty God he knows that
ABAB will never accept Islam
falsification test 10
years there's another falsification test
many many are there
it's mentioned in Sur Bak chapter number
two verse number 94 95 there was a group
of Jews who are having confrontation
with the
Muslims and they say that the last home
with Allah is only for us so Allah says
in Surah Bak 2: 94 and 95 that if they
say the last home with Allah is only for
them so ask them to call for
death if you say that surely the last is
for you then call for death and the
verse continues they will never call for
death
never only thing these Jews had to do to
prove the Quran wrong was say I want to
die so easy not that they had to die not
that they to commit suicide not that
they to stab themselves only thing they
to say is I want to die so easy to prove
the Quran wrong you want to say I want
to die four words Quran will be proved
wrong
Allah continues in Surah Bak CH 2 vers
95 and 96 they will never call for death
even if a thousand years was given to
them so easy so easy to prove the Quran
wrong now these two falsification test
were FAL of the past now you'll ask me
brother Zak today I want to prove the
Quran wrong how can I prove it wrong
today
can I do it
today yes everyone has a
chance Allah says in Surah ma chapter
number five verse number
that for the Believers the closest to
the Believers are those people who say
that we are
Christians and the furthest away the
staunchest enemies are those who save a
Jews and pagans the Quran says the
staunchest enemies of the Believers are
the Jews and the pagans and the closest
to the Believers are those who say we
are
Christians as a whole the Quran is
talking as a whole there are many Jews
that have accepted Islam there may be
few Jews who are better than the
Christians but as a whole the Quran says
the
Jews are the enemies of the Muslim as a
whole and the Christians are closer only
thing to prove the Quran wrong now all
the Jews of the world they get together
and they plan
okay let's be good to the Muslim for a
few years or two three years better than
the
Christians Quran is proved wrong so easy
all the Jews of the world get together
for 3 four years we'll be good to the
Muslims and then we'll say this verse of
the Quran Surah ma chapter number 5
verse number 82 is
wrong they will never do it they will
never be able to do
it easy
there are other falsification test you
will say I'm not a
Jew but I want to prove the Quran wrong
how can I prove it Allah has given
everyone a
chance Allah says in the Quran in Surah
is chapter number 17 verse number 88 do
they say he forged
it try and produce a Quran like unto it
mean do you say the Quran is forged try
and produce a Quran like it
the same challenge is repeated in Surah
chapter number 52 verse number 34 Allah
challenges that try and produce the
Quran like it and you'll never be able
to do it even if all the
Gins and the humankind gathered together
they will never be able to produce the
like of the
Quran without the help of
Allah it's a challenge now Allah makes
the challenge
easier Allah says in Surah Hood chapter
number 11 verse number 13 do they say he
forged
it produce 10 suras forged like unto it
not the whole Quran difficult forget it
that challenge is difficult produce 10
suras like the
Quran and call forth for help anyone
besides Allah and you'll never be able
to do
it Allah makes the challenge easier much
easier
in Surah yunus chapter number 10 verse
number
38 do they say he forged it produce one
Surah like it one not the whole Quran
not 10 Surah one Surah like
it and call forth for help anyone who
you
want besides Allah and you'll not be
able to do
it no response now Allah makes the test
much easier Allah says in Surah Bak
chapter number two verse number 23 and
24 Allah
says and if you and doubt as what we
have revealed to our servant from time
to
time produce a Surah somewhat similar to
itly it's not misly mly means somewhat
similar not exactly like the Quran try
and produce one Surah somewhat similar
to the Quran
call forth for help and Witnesses anyone
you want besides Allah if you speak the
truth but if you
cannot and of assurity you
cannot and be prepared for the fire
whose fuel is men and Stones you will
not be able to do it and of for shity
you cannot do
it and be prepared for the fire whose
fuel is men in Stones this is a
challenge try and produce a Surah
somewhat similar to it now you'll tell
me but n if it is a test you have to
reproduce The Sur in Arabic brother Zak
I don't know Arabic how can I take part
in this test I said fine if you produce
a Surah like the Quran it has to be in
Arabic it can't be in English can't be
in French can't be in Hindi can't be in
Urdu many people tried not that they
didn't try many hundreds of people tried
and they failed miserably they were able
to rhyme it but went away from reality
many people tried and many are available
in the books but all of them failed
miserably now you'll ask me the brother
Zakir I don't know
Arabic I'm not a Jew how can I try and
prove the Quran wrong there are many
falsification test I'll give you one
more where anyone can take part I
started my talk by quoting a verse of
the Quran
from chapter number four verse number 82
which
says do they not consider the Quran with
care had it been from anyone besides
Allah anyone besides almighty God there
have been many
contradictions so if you want to prove
the Quran
wrong only thing you have to do is take
out a single contradiction in the Quran
if anyone takes out a single Contrition
the Quran the Quran will be proved wrong
not that people did not try many people
tried you go on the internet you will
find a thousand contradictions but all
of them either out of
context or M transation or
illogical so this is called as a
falsification test so Quran shows as a
way how to prove itself wrong if you
think it's not from God you want to
prove it wrong try it take out a single
contradiction the Quran will be proved
wrong this is called as the
falsification
test
anyone who believes in God will
immediately agree if he's unbiased with
what I've said in the
last one hour he have to agree that the
Quran is from
God but what about a person who does not
believe in God
himself if a person does not believe in
God where is the question of Quran being
a word of
God so now we have dealt with the
majority of the people but yet there is
a large percentage who are atheist who
do not believe in God
himself how do we deal with them
when I meet an
atheist and if he says that he does not
believe in God the first thing I do is I
congratulate that
atheist now you may wonder that why is
Zak congratulating an
atheist the reason I'm congratulating
him is because most of the human beings
they are doing Blind
belief most of the Christians the
Christians go the father is a Christian
he Hindu because father is Hindu some of
them are Muslims because their father
are Muslim they aren't
thinking this person he's thinking he
may be coming from a religious
background but he may not agree that the
god which his parents are
worshiping is wor to be called as
God the reason I congratulate atheist is
because he has said the first part of
the Islamic shahada Islamic creeda there
is no
God the only thing I have to do is prove
to him
illah but Allah which I shall do
inshallah to the other
non-muslims to the other non-muslims
first I have to prove to him that the
God is worshiping is false so half the
time I waste in trying to prove that the
God is worshiping is
false here half my job is donea
only thing left for me Allah and then
Muhammad but Allah and Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon the messenger of
Allah now this
atheist he rejects God
because he has a wrong concept of God
now anyone who says he does not believe
in God first I'll ask him what is the
definition of God for anyone to
reject anything he should know its
definition for
example if I say this is a
pen for you to say it is not a pen you
should know the definition of pen if you
don't know the definition of pen you
cannot say this is not a
pen is it clear do you agree with me or
not if I say this is a pen for you to
say it is not a pen you have to know the
definition of pen
otherwise you cannot logically say it's
not a
pen there was a smart person he said no
brother I know that's a book so even if
I don't know the definition of a pen I
can say it's not a
pen I know it's a
book so why should I know the definition
of pen so I said fine do you know that
auk he says yes I say this
this is aab if said no it's not
aab he knows the definition of book but
does not know a definition of
kitab kab in Arabic and Udu means a
book if I say this is a pen knowing
definition of a pen is more important
than knowing what is
this same way if a person says there's
no God I'll first ask him what is the
definition of God the definition they
give is when they see that a God tells a
lie a God can be
defeated the God he can be killed so
when we hear all these stories of God
telling a lie a God can be defeated a
God can be killed a God can die a god
requires to
eat so they reject the God who are they
rejecting they rejecting the false
gods similarly someone if he believes
that Islam is a religion of
terrorism Islam is a merciless religion
Islam is a unscientific religion Islam
is a religion which does not give rights
to the woman and he rejects this Islam I
say even I reject such
Islam because I know that Islam is a
merciful religion Islam it's a
scientific Rel religion Islam has human
rights Islam has wom
rights so what do I do I tell him the
Islam you believe and you reject it
should be rejected but true Islam is
then I present to him the true Islam
similarly when these people are
rejecting the false God we have to
present to them what is the true God and
the best definition of almighty
God of Allah subhana wa tala given in
the Quran is from surlas chapter number
12 12 verse number 1 to 4 which
says say he is Allah one and
only Allah Allah the absolute and
eternal he begets not nor is
begotten there is nothing like him this
is a forline definition of Allah subhana
wa taala any person saying that so and
so person is God if that person fits in
this forine definition we Muslims have
got no objection in accepting that
person as
God the first
is says Allah one and only second is
Allah Allah the absolute
Eternal he begets not know he
begotten there's nothing like
him there are many people who say that
Das Nish he almighty God let us put this
bhagan dashes to the test of
surlas there's a person who ask me
question answer time that brother Zak
Hindus do not believe in bhagavan needs
to be God I never said
that Hindus believe bhagavan need to be
God I've read the Hindu scriptures
nowhere do the Hindu scriptures say
bhagan is God I said some human beings
some people believe bhagan to be God let
us put this bhagan to the test of surlas
the first
is say is Allah one and only was bhagan
rajish one and only was he the only man
who claimed Divinity there are hundreds
who have claimed Divinity and in this
country alone there are thousands who
have claimed that they were Gods he's
not the only one but the rashish B will
say no he is one and only is unique
let's go to the next
test Allah Allah the absolute Eternal
was rajish absolute Eternal we know from
the autobiography of
rajnish he says that he was
suffering from astha from chronic
backache from diabetes mtis imagine
almighty god of uffing from ASA chronic
backache diabetes
malius third test
is he beets not know he's begotten we
know bhagan rajnish he was born in Mad
Pradesh and later on in 1981 he goes to
America and takes thousands of American
for a ride and in the state of Oregon he
starts his village called as
risham later on the American government
they arrest him and they put him behind
bars
and rajnish he Alles that the American
government they slow poison in the
prison imagine almighty God being slow
poisoned later on the American
government the king out the country he
comes back to India and goes back to the
city of
Puna where he has a center which is now
called as Oso
commune and when you go to the center
if you go to samadi it is mentioned
there on his samadi bhagan oh never born
never died but visited the Earth from
the 11th of December 1931 to the 19th of
January 1990 never born never died but
visited the
Earth from the 11th of December 1931 to
the 19th of January 1990 they forgot to
men mention on a samadi that he was not
given visas to more than 21 countries of
the
world almighty God coming to visit the
world and requires
visas and the Ark Bishop of Greece said
that if you don't remove rajish out of
this country we'll burn his house and
the house of a
disciple and the last
test there's nothing like him is so
stringent that no one besides the true
almighty God can pass the moment you can
compare God to anyone in this world to
anyone in the universe he's not
God there's nothing like
him suppose someone says that almighty
God is a thousand times stronger than
anus waser you might have heard the name
of anus waser the person who got the
title Mr world the strongest man in the
world Mr Universe the strongest man in
the
universe if someone says that almighty
God is thousand times stronger than
wasar the moment you can compare God to
anything in this world whether it be
annar whether it be D Singh whether it
be King Kong whether it be a thousand
times or million times the moment who
can compare God to anything in this
world he's not
God there's nothing like
him we know bhagan Rish he were white
clothes he had a beard he had two eyes
like the human beings one nose two hands
the moment you can compare God to
anything in this world he's not God
otherwise Allah says in the Quran in is
chter number 17 verse
110 say call upon Him by Allah or by by
whichever name you call upon him to him
belong the most beautiful
names you can call Allah by any name but
it should be a beautiful name it should
not conal picture it should be a name
given by
himself and this
message besides being mentioned in Surah
is 17 ver 110 it's also mentioned Sur
chter number 7 verse 180 in Sur CH
number 20 verse number 8 as well as Sur
hash 59 ver number 24 that to Allah
belong the most beautiful
names many of the
atheist they believe in science all
these arguments may not satisfy them
completely many of the
atheists they say that science is the
ytic they believe science is Ultimate so
let's try and prove to this group of
atheist also about the existence of
Allah subhana
tala so if I know that this atheist
believes only in science after
congratulating
him I'll ask him a simple question that
if Suppose there is equipment there is a
gadget who no one in the world has ever
seen and if that Gadget is bought in
front of you and if the question is
asked that who will be the first person
who will be able to take tell you the
mechanism of this
gadget that
atheist he may say after thinking for a
while the first person who will be able
to tell you the mechanism of a gadget
who no one in the world has ever seen no
one in the world knows about it he will
tell you that the creator of that
Gadget or he may say the maker of the
gadget he may say the inventor he may
say the producer he may say the
manufacturer whatever he says it will be
somewhat similar either Creator
manufacturer producer maker inventor
somewhat similar just keep that answer
at the back of your
mind the second person is the creator if
he says to somebody else he'll come to
know or a person who does a research but
that is
secondary you ask this
atheist that how did our universe come
into existence so he will tell you that
that our universe was initially one
primary nebulah then there was a
secondary separation a big bang which
gave rest to galaxies Stars Moon Sun and
the Earth on which we
live this he calls as the big bang you
ask him when did you come to know about
this creation of the universe about the
Big Bang he will tell you about 50 years
back 40 years back so you tell him this
thing what you're mentioning about the
Big Bang is already mentioned in the
Quran 1400 years ago inia chapter number
21 verse number 30 where Allah
says do not the unbeliever
see that the Heaven and the Earth were
joined together and we cloth them
aund what you're talking about the big
bang is already mentioned in the Quran
14400 years ago who could have mentioned
this in the Quran so he will tell maybe
it's a fluk somebody wrote it no problem
don't argue with him
ask him the next question what is the
shape of the earth so he will tell you
previously the human beings thought that
the world was flat it was in 1577 when s
Francis Drake he sailed around the earth
that he proved that the Earth was
spherical you tell him that the Quran
mentions in chapter number 79 verse
number 30
that we have made the Earth XG shape the
Arabic word d one of its meaning is an
expanse and the Earth is an expanse the
other meaning is derived from the Arabic
word duya which means an egg and we know
today that the Earth is not completely
round like a ball it is stutting from
the pole and bulging from the center it
is GEOS sperical in shape it is somewhat
similar to egg and the Arabic word duya
does not refer to a normal egg it
specifically refers to the Egg of an
ostrich and if you analize the shape of
the Egg of an ostrich it is geosphere
ship imagine the Quran mentions that the
Earth is jeos sperical 1400 years ago
who could have mentioned that so he will
tell you ah your Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon Him intelligent man don't argue
continue the light of the moon is it its
own line of reflected light so theist
will tell you previously we thought that
the light of the moon was its own light
but today we know that the light of the
moon is not its own light it's a
reflected light when did you come to
know he will tell you we came to know
yesterday 50 years back 100 years back
200 years back Quran mentions 400 years
ago in Surah fan chapter number 25 verse
number
61 that blessed is he who had placed the
constellation in the sky and therein Sun
Shams having its own light and moon
having borrowed light the Arabic word
for sun is Shams its light is always
described as s of Aaj meaning a torch or
a blazing lamp and the Moon in Arabic is
called Asar its light is always
described as M or n m means borrowed
light and N means the reflection of
light and nowhere is the Moonlight
described as vaj it's always described
as n or borrowed light or reflection of
light who could have mentioned this in
the Quran 1400 years
ago now there'll be a pause don't wait
for the
reply continue
when I was in school I had
learned that the sun revolved but it was
stationary it did not rotate about
saxes the Quran says in Surah Ambia
chapter number 21 verse number
33 it is Allah who has created the night
and the day the Sun and the
Moon each one traveling in an orbit with
its own motion the Arabic word yes bahun
describes the of a moving body and if
it's talking about a cestal body it
means that this Sun and the Moon besides
revolving it's also rotating about its
own axis and today science tells us that
the sun takes approximately 25 days to
complete one rotation imagine what I
read in school I finished my school 1982
son was
stationary 1,00 years before the Quran
says the sun
rotates and my science book said the sun
was stationary today it has been
Incorporated that the sun
rotates you ask him that who could have
mentioned this there'll be a silent
pause some critics will say it's nothing
great that the Quran speaks about
astronomy because the Arabs were
advanced in the field of astronomy I do
agree the Arabs were advanced in the
field of astronomy but I like to remind
them that it was centuries after the
Quran was revealed that the Arabs became
advanced in the field of astronomy so it
is from the Quran that the Arabs learned
about astronomy and not the vice versa
in the subject of hology when you ask
the atheist that you ask him about the
water cycle he will tell you that the
water evaporates from the ocean it forms
into clouds the clouds move into the
interior it falls on as rain and the
water table is replenished I ask him
when did you come to know this he will
tell you it was in 1580 when sir Bernard
palac he spoke about the water cycle for
the first time 1580
so you tell him what you came to know in
5980 just
hardly couple of hundred years before
the Quran mentions 1400 years ago the
Quran
says the water evaporates from the ocean
formed into the clouds the clouds move
and join the moon in the interior and
they fall down rain and the VA table
finished the water cycle is spoken in
the Quran in great detail in several
places mentioned Sur zum chapter 39
verse number 21 in Sur room chapter
number 30 verse number 24 in chapter
number 15 verse number 22 in chapter
number 23 verse number 18 in Room
chapter number 30 ver number 48 in Sur n
chter number 24 ver number 43 it's
mentioned in Sur CH number 78 vers
number 12-4 it's mentioned in Sur chter
number 7:57 in Sur chter number 13 verse
number 17 it's mentioned Sur fan chter
number 25 verse number 48 and
49 it's mentioned in Surah Yassin
chapter number 36 verse number 34 it's
mentioned Sur F chter number 35 vers
number 9 it's mentioned in Sur jha chter
number 45 vers number 5 in Sur chter
number 50 verse number 9 and 10 it's
mentioned Sur chter 56 verse number 67
to 70 it's mentioned Sur chter 86 verse
number 11 I can go on and go on and go
on quoting only the verses in the Quran
which speak about the water cycle only
the Quran speaks about the water cycle
in great
detail who could have mentioned this in
the Quran 14 years ago
no reply don't worry
continue the Quran speaks about
geology the geologist say that the
radius of the Earth is 3,750 mil the
deeper layers are hot and fluid the
upper lay is a thin crust hardly 1 to 20
miles in thickness and there high
possibility it will shake it is due to
the folding phenomena which gives rise
to mountain ranges which prevents the
Earth from shaking Allah mentioned this
in the Quran it's mentioned in the Quran
inah chapter number
78 verse number seven as well as eight
Allah
says we have made the Earth as an
expanse and the mountains as
pegs which science has agreed today a
similar message is
mentioned inia chapter 21 verse number
31 that we have placed on the earth
Mountain standing firm lest it would
shake with you in the field of
oceanology previously we knew that there
was two types of water salt and sweet
but the Quran says in Sur fan 25 verse
number
53 that it is he who has let free two
bodies of flowing water one sweet and
palatable the other salty and bitter
though they meet they do not mix there
is a barrier which is Forin to be
trespassed we knew that there were two
types of water but what does the Quran
mean there is a barrier which is
forbidden to be trespassed today we know
that whenever one type of water flows
into the other type of water it loses
its constituents and gets homogenized
into the water it flows this
homogenizing area is called as a barrier
a Barak in the
Quran Quran mentioned this 14 years
ago Quran mentioned about
biology it's mentioned Sur Amia chapter
number 21 verse number
30 we have created every living thing
from water will not didn't believe who
could have believed in the deserts of
Arabia that everything is made from
water today science tells us that every
living thing is made from
water there is a theory known as theory
of
probability that if you make a wild
guess the chances you'll be right it
depending upon what are the options for
example if I toss a coin head or tails
whatever reply you give the chance
you'll be right is 1 upon two H
50% two options chances you'll be right
is 1 upon two 50% if I cost a to twice
the chances I'll be right both the times
is 1 upon 2 into 1 upon 2 it is 1 upon 4
it is
25% if I toss a coin thce the chances
I'll be right all three times is 1 upon
2 into 1 upon 2 into 1 upon two it is 1
upon 8 12 and a
half% if I throw a
dice the dice has got six sides the
chances if I make a wild guess it will
be right is 1 upon six now if you apply
this theory of probability that someone
made a wild
guess for example what is the shape of
the earth you can think of 10
things flat Square rectangle triangular
hexagonal on and on maybe
spherical the chances if you make a wild
guest it is fical it will be right is 1
upon
10 if you ask a person the light of the
moon is its own light or reflected light
if he makes a wild guess Chan he'll be
right as one upon two the chances that
both are right the shape of the earth
and the light of the moon is not its own
light is 1 upon 10 into 1 upon 2 is 1
upon 20 that is
5% all living creatures made of what you
can think of a thousand things
sand iron tin wood on and on maybe even
water
chances you make a wild guess and one is
right is one upon thousand chances all
three are
correct shape of the earth is spherical
light of the moon is reflected
everything made from water is 1 upon 10
into 1 upon 2 into 1 upon th000 is 1
upon
20,000 is
05% only only in
three scientific facts it's
05% I've already mentioned several and
if you read my book there are
hundreds there are many things Quran
speaks about botony in Surah chapter
number 13 verse number three that all
the fruits are created in pairs in Sexes
male and female Quran says in Sur
chapter number 20: 53 that the plants
are made in Sexes male and female which
you came to know recently in the field
of zoology Quran says the animals and
the birds live in community like the
human beings in Surah Anam chapter
number 6 verse number 38 which we came
to know recently Quran speaks about the
bee that it can find its path which we
came to recently in Surah Nel chapter
number 16 verse number 6 and 69 the
Quran says that the worker be the female
be previously thought it was the male
bee Quran says in Sur n chapter number
16 verse number 69 that the worker be
the female be Quran speaks about the
lifestyle of the spider in Surah anab CH
29 vers number 41 the Quran speaks about
the lifestyle of the ant in Surah namal
chapter number 27 verse number 17 18
which we have come to recently Quran
speaks about genetics that it is a male
fluid it is the sperm which is
responsible for the sex of the child in
Surah naam chapter number 53 verse
number 45 and 46 as well as chapter
number 75 verse number 37- 39 which we
came to recently Quran speaks about
embryology that all the human beings are
made from alak a leash like substance
something which clings
in 96 verse number two which we came to
recently Quran speaks about the various
emical
stages
mud in Sur chapter number 23 verse
number 12 to 14 which we have come to
recently there are various scientific
facts mentioned in the
Quran I'll just mention two
more there are people who say that after
human beings die and after we are buried
and our bones are disintegrated how will
Allah subhana tala be able to
reconstruct the bone on the day of
judgment so Allah
says it's mentioned in the Quran chapter
number 75 verse number 3 and 4 that when
they say that how will Allah be able to
reconstruct the bones of the day of
judgment tell them Allah can not only
reconstruct the bones he can even
reconstruct in perfect order the very
tip of your finger what does Allah mean
by saying he can not only reconstruct
your bones he can even reconstruct in
perfect order the very tips of your
finger it was in 1880 that s Francis
gold he discovered the fingerprinting
method and said that no two fingerprints
even in a million human beings are
identical today the police the C the FBI
the CIA they use the fingerprinting
method to identify the criminal Quran
speaks about the fingerprinting method,
1400 years ago and we discovered in 188
who could have mentioned
this I would like to mention one more
thing before I end the scientific facts
is that there was a scientist by the
name
ofan Professor Tashan haed from Thailand
and he was doing a great deal of
research in the pain
receptors previously we human beings we
thought and the doctors thought that
only the brain was responsible for the
feeling of pain
today we come to know that there are
certain receptors in the skin which are
also responsible for the feeling of pain
that's the reason when a person of burn
injury comes to a doctor the doctor
takes a pin and Pricks it in the area of
burn if the patient feels pain the
doctor is Happy the pain receptors are
intact if the patient does not feel pain
the doctor is sad the pain receptors
have been
destroyed it's mentioned in the Quran in
Surah NAA chapter number four verse 56
that as to those who reject our signs we
shall cast them in the Hellfire and as
often as the Skins are roasted we shall
give them fresh skin so that they feel
the pain indicating there is something
in the skin which is responsible for the
feeling of
pain imagine Quran speaks about the pain
deceptor 1400 years ago and Professor
Tashan when he came to know this mention
in the Quran in the ninth medical
conference in Riyad in the conference
itself he said the sh and
said muham there's no God but Allah and
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon the
messenger of
Allah so when you ask the atheist who
could have mentioned this in the Quran
the only reply I can give you is the
same which he gave you earlier it is the
creator it is the maker it is the
producer it is the manufacturer it is
the inventor this Creator this producer
this manufacturer this maker this
inventor we Muslims call him as Allah
that's the reason today science is not
eliminating God it is eliminating models
of God
ill scientists
today they eliminating models of God
this cannot be God this cannot be God
they aren't eliminating God and a famous
philosopher and scientist Francis Bacon
he said that those who have little
knowledge of science they become atheist
but those who have indepth knowledge of
science they become a believer in God I
would like to end my talk with the
quotation of the Quran from Sur chapter
41 verse number 53 which
says that soon we shall show them our
signs into the furthest region of the
horizons and into the souls until it is
clear to them that this is the truth
alhamdulillah
[Applause]